"Турборежим" звучало в позитивному контексті.
Ви вважаєте таку оплату справедливою за вашу роботу?
Я дуже хочу почути від тих, хто критикує рівень зарплат,
позицію: а яка
справедлива зарплата для члена уряду?
Казали, що літак збили, а українське керівництво
все ще казало: це не перевірено, ми чекаємо на підтвердження...
Всередині в нас владу критикують,
а зовні, навпаки, хвалять за принциповість і виваженість.
У СБУ заберуть непритаманні функції?
Ціль не в тому, щоб щось забрати або віддати.
Ціль у тому, щоб зробити ефективну інституцію.
Ви - віддана Зеленському людина?
Я - все життя віддана українській державі людина.
Пане Дмитре, дякую, що знайшли час для інтерв'ю.
Щодо підсумків засідання Україна-НАТО.
Україну хвалили за виконання річного плану 2019 року щодо співпраці з НАТО?
Дуже хвалили. Відзначали і якість змін,
і масштаб змін, і навіть швидкість змін.
Слово "турборежим" звучало в позитивному контексті.
Водночас колеги заохотили Україну, закликали нас
не йти надто швидко за рахунок якості для того,
щоб ми надалі забезпечували якісне законодавство,
яке ми ухвалюємо для того, щоб реформувати країну.
А за що найбільше хвалили?
Найбільше хвалили за реформи в сфері боротьби з корупцією,
тому що дійсно було ухвалено низку важливих законів,
підчистили низку актів законодавства,
які створювали умови для корупції і, по суті,
перезавантажили НАЗК, створили необхідні умови для роботи НАБУ,
відновили кримінальну відповідальність за незаконне збагачення,
тобто це все те, на чому наші партнери давно наполягали
і давно просили, щоб ми це зробили.
За що лаяли Україну?
Я б не казав, що лаяли.
Є питання, в яких просто союзники потребують
додаткового інформування з нашого боку або додатково спільної роботи,
щоб акти законодавства, які ми ухвалюємо
або імплементуємо, максимально відповідали стандартам,
звичним для наших партнерів по НАТО.
І це стосується судової реформи і питання реформи СБУ.
Але запевняли, що діалог є, і, наприклад,
щодо законопроекту щодо реформи СБУ ми повністю взаємодіємо
з Альянсом, чуємо їхні аргументи, вони чують наші
і робота ведеться.
Коли ухвалять цей законопроєкт? Бо той, який подав Баканов, завис, так?
Була перша версія законопроєкту, вона була
проговорена з Альянсом, деякі речі були змінені.
Зараз є друга версія, вона незабаром також буде проговорена з НАТО.
А потім все залежатиме від порядку денного Верховної Ради і того,
як цей законопроєкт проходитиме стіни парламенту.
У СБУ заберуть непритаманні їй повноваження?
Життя покаже. Ціль не в тому, щоб забрати або надати,
а в тому, щоб зробити ефективну інституцію
та знайти такий баланс повноважень, який,
з одного боку, відповідатиме положенням закону
про національну безпеку України, а з іншого,
максимально наблизить СБУ до її натівських аналогів.
Водночас союзники чітко усвідомлюють, що є низка
специфічних загроз, з якими стикається Україна найбільше,
і вони теж потребують реагування СБУ.
Україна отримає Програму розширених можливостей?
Це було одне з ключових питань, які я порушував
і обговорював під час зустрічей тут, у Брюсселі.
Ми абсолютно переконані, що ми маємо отримати статус учасника цієї програми.
Більше того, є документ НАТО, в якому написано, що
ми відповідаємо вимогам.
Для нас це принципово важливо - стати учасником програми,
яка продемонструє високий рівень довіри,
який існує між НАТО і Україною, усуне низку
операційних проблем у взаємодії і створить
нові можливості для взаємодії між Україною і Альянсом.
А конкретно що вона дасть Україні?
Я наведу дуже простий приклад.
Є навчання натівські, які, коли визначають
правила проведення цих навчань, пишуть - учасники навчань:
країни-члени і країни-учасники EOP -
- Програми розширених можливостей.
Тобто якщо ти не є учасником, ти випадаєш із навчань.
Другий момент - дуже важливий елемент
програми розширених можливостей -
поглиблений і швидший обмін розвідувальними даними між учасниками цієї програми.
Зараз багато в Україні обговорюють збільшення зарплат урядовцям.
Я правильно зрозумів, що Ви в грудні отримали 87 тисяч гривень?
Ні, я не отримував таких грошей за жоден місяць роботи в уряді.
Та цифра, яка потрапила в інформаційний простір, -
це сума до податків і зборів.
На місяць я в середньому отримую в районі 50 тисяч гривень, 50-52,
і, якщо не помиляюся, саме такі гроші я отримав у грудні.
Але я був би щасливий отримувати ту суму, яку назвали в ЗМІ,
але ні, її в моєму гаманці немає.
Але до вирахування усіх податків і зборів ця цифра правильна?
Так. Але я не отримаю такі гроші в кишеню.
А Ви вважаєте таку оплату справедливою за Вашу роботу?
Я дуже хочу почути від тих, хто критикує рівень зарплат,
позицію, а яка
справедлива зарплата для члена уряду.
А як Ви вирахуєте справедливу для себе?
Справедлива зарплата - це та сума, яка дозволяє мені
спокійно забезпечувати свою сім'ю і гідно
винагороджує мої зусилля з захисту національних інтересів України.
У нас в цій дискусії відсутній один важливий елемент.
Є дуже багато критики, що ви отримуєте забагато.
Чи я особисто не отримую забагато.
Але абсолютно відсутня розмова про те, а скільки, власне,
що суспільство або експертне середовище вважає
справедливою винагородою для члена уряду за його зусилля.
То, може, уряду треба запропонувати якусь схему:
оце ми вважаємо справедливим, щоб всі розуміли, що так, це справедливо.
Бо з тих цифр, які були озвучені,
якщо один міністр отримує 230 тисяч, Ви отримуєте 50 тисяч,
а до вирахування це 87 тисяч, а (міністр Кабінету Міністрів Дмитро. - Ред.) Дубілет отримує найменше.
Дуже велика різниця.
Є дуже різні міністри. У деяких членів уряду
є фінансові подушки, які дозволяють їм не зважати на офіційну зарплату.
У деяких їх немає. У мене, наприклад,
немає якоїсь фінансової подушки, я живу на одну зарплату.
Я жив на зарплату посла, яку я отримував, працюючи при Раді Європи.
Ця зарплата дозволила мені зробити заощадження,
частину яких я зараз витрачаю щомісяця для того,
щоб покривати ті фінансові розриви, які виникають через ту зарплату,
яку я отримую в Україні. Вся ця дискусія про зарплати - це, знаєте...
Ясно, що добре атакувати уряд, владу, кричати:
ви забагато отримуєте.
Це все святе, люди це люблять, я поважаю право людей робити такі речі.
Але суспільство має визначитися,
що от ми вважаємо, що член уряду заслуговує на таку зарплату.
Ми тоді скажемо: а давайте поговоримо, можливо,
це все-таки замало, або знаєте, це забагато, ми собі менше хочемо зарплату.
Грати в популізм - це не призводить до добра.
Пані Олену Зеркаль, я так розумію, Ви добре знаєте.
Вона нещодавно сказала, що Зеленському,
як і його попередникам, подобається працювати з "відданими людьми, а не з професійними".
Ви - віддана Зеленському людина?
Я - все життя віддана українській державі людина.
Я прийшов на державну службу у 2003 році,
і якби я був відданий якомусь конкретному президенту, а не державі,
то я думаю, що моя кар'єра закінчилася б одразу після того президента,
і я би пішов разом з ним. Я служу українській державі та завжди їй служив.
Що стосується заяв про відданість, то безумовно,
поруч із президентом мають працювати люди, яким він довіряє.
Але довіра і відданість - це не є за визначенням погані речі.
Мені подобається реформаторський порядок денний,
який реалізує президент Зеленський.
Союзникам по НАТО подобається цей порядок денний,
вони сьогодні неодноразово відзначали
надзвичайно важливу та конструктивну роль
президента в реформах і врегулюванні конфлікту на сході України.
До речі, сьогодні і керівництво Альянсу,
і багато союзників відзначили дуже позитивно те,
як Україна відреагувала
на збиття українського літака в Ірані.
Вони відзначили, що ми відреагували принципово,
водночас без емоцій, гідно, з повагою до жертв.
Це якраз той стиль, який відповідає їхньому баченню, їхнім стандартам.
Але в Україні лунала саме критика на адресу Зеленського,
що коли вже західні партнери казали,
що літак збили, українське керівництво все ще казало,
що це не перевірено, ми чекаємо на підтвердження, докази...
Бо у тих партнерів на той момент був доступ
до конкретних даних їхніх розвідок. До речі,
якби ми були вже частиною цієї Програми розширених можливостей НАТО,
то обмін цими розвідданими був би швидшим, більш оперативним і ефективним.
У нас дійсно існує абсолютно протилежне сприйняття
позиції України щодо літака всередині країни та ззовні країни.
Всередині у нас владу критикують, а ззовні, навпаки,
хвалять за принциповість і виваженість. Тобто це
була і принципова позиція, і водночас було використане слово non-escalatory,
тобто це не були дії, які призводили до подальшої ескалації
ситуації довкола збиття літака.
Давайте трохи поговоримо про ЄС.
Одна з цілей України - внесення змін або модернізація угоди про асоціацію.
Коли чекати перших змін?
Угода про асоціацію - це тіло угоди плюс протоколи до неї.
Ми говоримо про внесення змін до протоколів...
До додатків, які вирішують якісь конкретні питання.
Я думаю, що ми присвятимо 2020 рік переговорам
із Європейським Союзом щодо того, якими саме мають бути ці зміни,
бо у нас є інтереси, є у них інтереси, і ці інтереси потрібно збалансувати.
Цей рік в цьому плані буде дуже активним.
Плюс ми хочемо укласти новий протокол, а саме
про так званий промисловий безвіз,
Угоду про визнання сертифікатів промислової продукції...
Так. Коли я говорив з чиновниками ЄС
про промисловий безвіз, вони дуже обережні.
Іноді складається враження, що вони хочуть дати Україні зрозуміти,
що тут Україна занадто амбітна і що, може, якось
їй показати, що навряд чи Україна отримає його.
Ви знаєте, в якому році Україна і ЄС вперше
підписали документ, присвячений цій угоді?
Це міститься в угоді про асоціацію.
У 2005 році, ще до угоди про асоціацію.
Це був спільний план дій щодо приведення української системи
технічного регулювання, технічних регламентів
у відповідність до стандартів ЄС.
Тому якщо хтось у Єврокомісії хоче дати Україні зрозуміти,
що цього не буде, що промислового безвізу не буде,
я закликаю якнайшвидше їх це зробити,
але дуже гарно обґрунтувати,
чому саме вони так вважають.
Бо і з точки зору наявних юридичних передумов,
і з точки зору тих реформ, які вже запровадила Україна,
немає жодної фундаментальної перешкоди для укладення цієї угоди.
Ще багато чого нам треба зробити, але є два шляхи:
або колеги з Євросоюзу будуть гальмувати на цьому шляху,
або будуть сприяти його проходженню.
Якщо сприятимуть, ми пройдемо цей шлях швидше.
Якщо гальмуватимуть, ми цей шлях все одно пройдемо, але це займе більше часу.
В ЄС часто говорять про децентралізацію як історію успіху в реформах в Україні.
Але цього тижня був лист до Зеленського,
де критикують законопроєкт про зміни до Конституції в плані децентралізації,
що вони навпаки зменшать досягнення децентралізації,
зменшать повноваження громад.
Ви про це з ЄС контактуєте?
У нас
з вересня минулого року
було вже декілька випадків, коли певні законопроєкти
викликали занепокоєння наших партнерів по ЄС,
але ми в абсолютній більшості випадків
знаходили порозуміння й виходили на прийнятний результат.
Подивимося, що буде з тим законопроєктом,
який Ви згадали. Якщо я правильно розумію,
лист, на який ви посилаєтеся, то його написав пан Мільбрадт,
представник, делегований Німеччиною радник,
для реалізації реформи децентралізації.
З боку уряду я хочу запевнити, що уряд буде рішуче
проводити реформу децентралізації, бо ми бачимо
великі переваги від неї, і я не бачу, чому вона має зупинитися.
І наостанок:
складається враження, що Україна втратила пріоритет
на порядку денному ЄС і НАТО. Це так?
Не помітив я цього в НАТО, сьогодні зокрема.
А в ЄС, знаєте, мені один комісар сказав минулого року,
що тут у міжвиборчий період стало якось менше України,
але тепер стало знову багато.
Я йому пообіцяв, що України буде ще більше у 2020 році й надалі.
Це те, над чим ми працюємо.